-Vladimir Putin once again
threatened the world
by climbing Russia was
not bluffing
with its threat to use
nuclear weapons
in its brutal war
against Ukraine,
a threat that prompted
Donald Trump to once again
say something totally insane
and incoherent.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
has been going terribly
for Russia recently,
with Ukrainian forces
pushing back Russian troops
and regaining control
of large swaths of territory,
so now that Putin is backed
into a corner,
he's threatening once again
to look inward
and see how he can change
to become not just
a better leader,
but also a better man.
Oh, wait. Nope. Sorry.
Read that wrong.
He's threatening once again
to trigger a nuclear war.
-Vladimir Putin announces
a major escalation
in his totally unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine,
the Russian president calling up
300,000 military reservists
and threatening to use
nuclear weapons.
-Vladimir Putin doubling down in
his war against Ukraine,
in a national address,
ordering up more troops
after a series of setbacks
and vowing Russia will use
"all means at its disposal"
and he added,
"I am not bluffing."
-Okay,
the problem with Putin is,
even if he was bluffing,
it would be impossible to tell.
The guy is a former KGB agent
and he's addicted to Botox.
[ Laughter ]
His expression never changes.
It doesn't matter if
he's losing a war
or riding a roller coaster.
[ Laughter ]
He wouldn't even crack a smile
if Paul Hollywood
shook his hand!
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating Putin ]
"I'm this week's Star Baker.
Thank you. I feel nothing."
I mean, I can't think
of a single thing
that would make one
of the world's most evil
and dangerous men smile.
Oh, right.
[ Laughter ]
Like, in all seriousness,
can you imagine this guy
ever telling a joke?
You know how presidents
here in the US
have to do jokes every year
at the White House
Correspondent's Dinner?
Well, except for Trump,
who refused to do it,
because he got teased one year
by some dumb young kid
who didn't know any better
and then,
you know, ran for president.
You remember
M.C. Butterfly Effect over here.
Anyway, imagine if Putin
had to do that in Russia.
[ Imitating Putin ] "They say
war in Ukraine is going badly.
Almost as badly
as press tour for
'Don't Worry, Darling.'
[ Laughter ]
If you laughed at that joke,
you will be poisoned.
And it is the worst
kind of poison,
because Harry Styles
spit in it.
Chris Pine knows
what I'm talking about."
[ Normal voice ]
World leaders are reportedly
making contingency plans
in response to Putin's threat,
as well as communicating
in private with Moscow
about just how bad
an idea that would be.
-We have communicated directly,
privately at very high levels
to the Kremlin
that any use of nuclear weapons
will be met
with catastrophic consequences
for Russia,
that the United States and our
allies will respond decisively,
and we have been
clear and specific
about what that will entail.
-We have communicated
to the Russians
what the consequences
would be,
but we've been careful in how
we talk about this publicly,
because from our perspective,
we want to lay down
the principle
that there would be
catastrophic consequences,
but not engage in a game
of rhetorical tit-for-tat.
-I guess it's at least
a relief to hear that,
after four years of nonstop tat
from the world's biggest tit.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
So as Russia loses more ground,
Putin and some
of his top officials
have been threatening to use
weapons of mass destruction.
And it's been a deeply
revealing study in contrast
to see how different
the reactions have been
from Joe Biden and Donald Trump.
First, there was Biden, who was
asked about the possibility
that Putin might use nukes on
"60 Minutes" earlier this month,
and adopted a very sober tone.
-As Ukraine succeeds
on the battlefield,
Vladimir Putin
is becoming embarrassed
and pushed into a corner.
And I wonder, Mr. President,
what you would say to him
if he is considering
using chemical
or tactical nuclear weapons.
-Don't.
Don't. Don't.
-I like when Biden treats
a world leader
like his dog Major threatening
to bite a Secret Service agent.
"Major, don't!
Don't do it, Major.
Damn it, Major!
Now, I got to send you
back to Scranton,
and I'm cutting you off
financially.
You'll have to go back
to tending bar."
Anyway, Biden continued
from there,
but he just didn't reveal
many details.
-It would change the face of war
unlike anything
since World War Two.
-And the consequences of that
would be what?
What would the U.S. response be?
-You think I would tell you if I
knew exactly what it would be?
Of course I'm not
going to tell you.
-Okay, but could you
tell us a little?
I would just love to know
if I need to start reinforcing
my desk with concrete
so I can use it as a bunker.
Because right now
all I have is my attic,
and that place
is filled with wasps.
Plus, I've been told
by many a YouTube commenter
that the lighting for my
home shows made me look like,
"young crypt keeper
or old Loki."
So Biden has been
stern but quiet
about how the US would respond.
Trump, meanwhile, has been
speculating wildly at rallies
and other events about insane
ideas like bombing Russia,
but blaming it on China
by putting Chinese flags
on a US fighter jets.
That's a real thing
he actually said.
It's one step removed
from Bugs Bunny
dressing up as a lady
to trick Elmer Fudd.
[ Imitating Trump ]
"Poor Elmer Fudd.
He had such a boner
for the ladies that when...
when he saw one
with pretty red lipstick,
he ignored the whiskers
and the buck teeth.
It wasn't until he saw the
cotton tail that he realized,
'Elmer, you've done it,
you've done it again, Elmer.
You've -- You've tried
to have sex with a rabbit.'"
And then this weekend
at a rally in North Carolina,
he brought up the topic of
nuclear weapons
in the weirdest and most
uncomfortable way possible.
-You know,
Putin mentioned the N-word.
You know what the N-word is?
-Now...
[ Laughter ]
...I have to imagine
there was some percentage
of that crowd,
however large or small,
that heard that sentence
and thought to themselves,
"Oh, my God,
it's finally happening!"
Meanwhile,
Biden was probably watching
that like this --
-The N-word! You know
what the N-word is?
-Don't.
Don't. Don't.
-And to be fair,
it seems like Trump sensed
what his crowd
was thinking, too,
because he quickly
had to clarify himself.
-You know what the N-word is?
It's --
No, no, no.
It's the "nuclear" word.
He mentioned
the N-word yesterday.
The nuclear word,
not supposed to be mentioned.
You could end up
in World War Three.
And this will be a war
like we've never had before.
It won't even be close,
because we're being
run by stupid people.
-Yeah, you know, stupid people,
like the kinds of people
who are refer to
the word "nuclear"
as "the N-word."
What's wrong with you?
Why would you shorten a word
no one shortens like that?
"You know, honey, I have to say,
your sister is a real C-word.
That's right.
She's a real charmer."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe he shortened it
because it's easier
than saying the word nuclear,
because at this rally,
there were times
when he clearly had trouble
getting any words
out of his mouth,
as evidenced
by whatever the hell
he was trying to say here.
-Our once-great country --
Remember, I was going to say,
I was gonna use an expression,
we have to keep
our country great --
but it's not -- I mean,
for some reason,
it's just not great anymore.
-I love that famous expression.
Very...
Did you crib that
from Winston Churchill?
You should put that on a hat.
[ Laughter ]
What happened to him there?
I would say he lost his place
in his script,
but he never follows
one to begin with.
It's also, I like when Trump
gets so confused,
he can't even find his way back
to one of his standard lines.
Like if you're really that lost,
just toss in a "crooked Hillary"
or a "lock her up" or something.
Instead, he turned into
Ralph Kramden.
"It's not I mean,
for some reason --
hummina-hummina-hummina."
By the way, we did
a "Honeymooners" joke last week,
and the audience went
as dead silent
is when Trump said
the phrase "the N-word."
And yet tonight, we decided
to call it back in a new segment
we've dubbed "Seth Doubles Down
on a Stinker."
-Hardy-har-har.
[ Laughter ]
Also, when it comes
to nuclear war,
I'm not sure we should be
taking advice from a guy
who stole highly sensitive,
classified documents
about a foreign country's
nuclear capabilities
and stashed them away
at his private beach club,
Mar-a-Lago.
I'm guessing they were just
laid out in tiny dishes
around his office
the way my grandmother
put out hard candies.
And by that, I mean
on every possible surface.
She loved a hard candy,
my grandmother.
Used to walk
into the candy shop and say,
"Give me something sweet
that's harder than
living through the Depression."
Now, as we told you last week,
an appeals court ruled that the
federal criminal investigation
into Trump's handling of those
documents can move forward.
And yet, oddly, there's only
one current or former president
Republicans seem focused
on impeaching, and it's not
the one facing multiple criminal
investigations and civil suits
he stole classified documents
from the White House
and fomented a violent coup
to overthrow American democracy.
-Congresswoman Nancy Mace
believes there is pressure
on House Republicans to try
and impeach President Joe Biden
if they take control
after the midterms.
-Do you expect
an impeachment vote
against President Biden
if Republicans take
over the House?
-I believe there's a lot
of pressure on Republicans
to have that vote,
to put that legislation
forward and to have that vote.
I think that is something
that some folks are considering.
-These people are so crazy.
The guy you support can't even
complete a full sentence.
In fact, I'm pretty sure
if you asked Republicans
what specifically they want to
impeach Biden for, they'd say --
-Gate -- buh-buh.
But it's not...I mean...
-I mean, what are you
going to impeach him for?
Not stealing
classified documents?
Wearing sunglasses inside?
Doing that thing where
he occasionally looks like
he's not sure where to stand and
just kind of get stuck on stage?
Look, it's funny, okay?
It's funny,
and it happens to all of us.
One time I got so lost
in the Mall of America,
I ended up just moving there
and getting a job
as an LL Bean mannequin.
[ Laughter ]
This is how badly
the Republican Party
has degraded the institutions
of our government.
They see power purely as a means
to reward themselves
and punish their enemies,
even in the midst
of major global crises
that should inspire
bipartisan cooperation.
Republicans want to impeach
Joe Biden for no reason,
but if you ask them
to hold Trump accountable,
even just a little bit,
they'd say --
-No, no, no.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up,
so to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.